in this course we will cover how value
chains can be leveraged and can be used
as a way to support innovations and
innovations can happen in multiple ways
so this course will talk about how you
can leverage the ecosystems your
suppliers your customers your outsource
providers all of them can be a part of
your innovation process and innovations
can also cover the product space as well
as the process space so we want to
describe how these innovations can occur
what are the basic principles the
trade-offs as well as the potential and
opportunities that one can achieve
through the value chain
I'm hoping that the participants by
going through this course will be able
to see the tremendous opportunities
there they have regardless of whether
they are is startup companies or whether
they are immature companies
opportunities of value chain innovations
are everywhere and they can happen with
any part of their value chain
I hope that all of us in your
professional lives would be able to
first be very very alert about the
opportunities around you and often times
we focus innovations to the product
space thinking that that's innovation I
want to come up with a new products I
want to come up with a revolutionary
products but in fact innovations can
occur in more than the proc space of
course products are important but the
way you make the product the way you
introduce the product the way you
service your customers after the product
has been sold or delivered to the
customers and how you can regain the
values from making services out of the
products all of those are innovations
and so I hope that our participants
recognize that innovations is much
broader than products and the values can
be tremendous if you look beyond your
four walls and see how you can build
lasting relationship with the whole
value chain and leveraging the power of
the value chain that's what I hope our
participants would make use of from
going through this course as well as in
their professional life beyond what
they're doing today